The general Hogan experience.
I was doing my first documentary back in 1997,
when I was just naive enough to think I can get an interview with Steven
Spielberg. We had a mutual friend involved, uh, this woman, Janet,
and she gets back to me and she's like, yeah. So, uh,
Spielberg's definitely not going to meet with you,
but he knows you're working on this UFO documentary.
He thinks you should look into this landing case that happened in Africa at the
school. And I said to myself at the time and remind, you know,
remind you guys that I was making a film on UFO's and I dismissed it so
quickly because I thought there's no way that a mass
landing with the sheer volume of eyewitness testimony at a
school in broad daylight could happen in the whole world, not know about it.
So I just walked away from that story for about 10 years, 10 years later,
I'm doing an event at the national press club with, with Leslie cane who, uh,
was, um, part of the article in New York times.
It came out in 2017 and she introduced me to this guy, uh,
Randall Nickerson. And she's like, Oh,
he's working on this landing case in Africa, long story short, uh,
he's working on a film. Uh, now I think it's coming out next year,
specifically on just that case. Uh,
Dan Farrah is producing it and he said, um,
I'm working on the case. And if you want to do something with me on it,
a small piece, I could. So I got back into it.
I licensed some of the footage that Dr. John Mack,
the Harvard psychiatrist that came and interviewed the school children on camera
within a week of it happening. He unfortunately looked the wrong way in London,
got run down by a car and died.
So I contacted the Institute with the help of Randall Nickerson.
I licensed the archival footage. We tracked down the witnesses today.
We flew them in from all different corners of the world, brought them together.
A lot of them were standing right next to each other.
These they came face to face.
And one of the things I realized was that there were roughly a hundred kids in
the playground, broad daylight, Ariel school ruse and Bob way,
1994.
And they got within arms re armed some of them within an arm's length of these
beans and brought these witnesses together for the first time in 20 years.
And a lot of them hadn't even told their, their, you know,
significant others just because they said they were tired of having to defend
this. And I myself didn't believe it when I first heard about it back in 1997.
And that segment of the film is the most, in my opinion,
is the most powerful segment, because very compelling.
You've got all these children's saying what they saw on camera after it
happened. And then you see them 20 years later.
And then we go to Africa and we meet with the headmistress,
or she was a teacher at the time we went with other witnesses.
We go to the landing site. We talked to people at the school.
That case is absolutely.
And it was witnessed by lots of other people in and around the area for several
days before it chose a school to land.
It's so compelling because the children are all clearly, they're not actors.
So as they're adults later, they're all talking about this moment.
And it's like, they had a religious experience together.
Like they're all sharing it and talking about it. And you could tell it's like,
it's a deeply moving experience. If they were actors,
they wouldn't have been able to do such a good job because it's it to convey the
reality of that moment to them, to, to, to,
to be able to have this interpretation of this event,
where they're all consistent in the story.
And they're all clearly still shook by this moment.
It's really interesting because if you had that scene in a movie,
it would take like a really good actor to pull it off.
And they'd probably need multiple takes. It'd probably want to get the best one,
but those kids,
the way they were talking about it and the way they were drawing it,
you're like, wow, it really does seem like something happened.
I,
I know how credible that the testimony of the children is because my partner,
Rebecca,
she's never had much of an interest in what I do making documentaries on UFO's.
I do other things as well. But when I was reviewing in the studio,
uh, the archival interview of the children,
she just dropped off a cup of coffee and she stopped and he went, Oh my God,
those children are not line. This is the most amazing thing I've ever seen,
because look, I ask your audience to, don't take it for me.
Just suspend judgment for a moment.
And imagine hypothetically,
if a UFO or several UFO's landed at a school
in broad daylight in ruin Zimbabwe Africa and interacted
telepathically with nearly a hundred school children,
not all of them had telepathic, but it seen the incident.
How significant of a story would you give them?
Well, not only that they had the same message. Yes.
But the telepathic message was that technology is a real problem.
And there's things that people are doing with technology that are going to ruin
the earth. Yes. And they were trying to relay this to children,
which is very strange, you know, I mean,
maybe they just thought they were adults because they were the same sizes of the
aliens. I mean, do you think they knew that they were children?
Do you think they understood that it was a school? I mean,
this is all speculation, right.
But I know, I definitely had to ask myself,
look during the production of the film,
Paula Harris actually turned me on to another landing case that happened in
Australia in 1966 at a school.
And this time there were roughly 300 witnesses that saw a disc
land, uh, right outside of a playground in Australia.
And we went to Australia and investigated that case, went to the landing site,
talk to eyewitness testimony that people that jumped the fence at the school
playground and ran over to where this thing landed.
And then we even interviewed a guy who snapped a photograph of a desk,
a Polaroid back in 1966, two days prior to the incident.
So it's very, uh, probably that we have a photo.
We have photographic evidence. We have, uh, eye witness testimony.
And for the first time we've got testimony from a science teacher.
So why do these things land at schools?
It seems like, and I'm just totally speculating here, but it seems like if,
if I were going to do that, it seems like a pretty benign environment.
When we've had testimony for military guys that we take a fairly hostile
position towards, uh, things that penetrate sensitive military installations.
And, um, you know, so maybe I'm just saying maybe,
maybe they save you.
Yeah. We have to stop reacting to, uh, you know,
intrusions by UFO's as a threat. I mean,
that's the whole thing behind this new task for us. And as much as I respect,
you know, the task force, uh,
my colleagues and I want to cooperate with them to the extent that we can bring
information or resources to what they do,
but there is more, this is not,
should not be looked at specifically as a threat. I mean, with,
with the phenomena that we observe, I mean,
if they wanted to blow up those FAA teams, I could do it. Okay.
Obviously that's, that's not what it's all about.
And this idea of just labeling it all as a, as a threat,
because it's unknown that that's a wrong idea.
90% of the information comes from the public comes from children,
comes in very, very little of it is made up, you know,
in France. I mean, the data we get, you know,
we had the French space agency comes through channels where if people
reported something that's found to be untrue,
they are going to be called by the police.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify,
watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.